in the run-up to today's arraignment the
former president used violent rhetoric
to Rally supporters echoing his words
from before the January 6 attack so the
NYPD has put up barricades around the
courthouse and introduced new security
measures in the city Chet pagayas is
outside Trump Tower with more Jeff good
morning
good morning Nate later on today early
afternoon time frame
or behind me and head south down into
Lower Manhattan for these historic
Corpus eatings
our message is clear and simple
control yourselves on Monday New York
city mayor Eric Adams warned potential
protesters and what he called rabble
rousers ahead of Donald Trump's
arraignment among the expected
demonstrators is GOP congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green a trump Ally who
tweeted her plan to protest to collect
Pond Park right across the street from
the courthouse NYPD commissioner kishan
Sewell the NYPD is prepared to ensure
that everyone is able to have their
voices heard peacefully while exercising
their first amendment rights
investigators from federal state and
local law enforcement say they've seen
calls for violence against Manhattan D.A
Alvin Brack government officials and the
FBI in preparation for Mr Trump's court
appearance clearly the entire New York
City police force is on standby I know
how well the New York City Police
Department is able to Pivot and shift
based on the circumstances that they are
facing and we are prepared I have no
concern at all around us
the police commissioner here in New York
City says that she has
resources she needs to protect public
officials who are facing serious threats
of course the NYPD 35
000 people strong the mayor says what
law enforcement has been saying over the
last couple of weeks that there are no
specific or credible threats they're
telling New Yorkers to go about their
daily business mate
Jeff thank you